And the seven years of plenty of snus that was in the land of Egypt branded in
the seven years of dearth began to come according as Joseph has said,
and a dearth was in all the lands.
Well,
that's an archetypal story,
right?
The archetypal story to the business cycle story.
It's a little harsher when you're starving,
obviously,
but that's not the point.
The point is is that sometimes things are getting good and sometimes things are
getting bad and that's,
you can be sure that that's the case that's going to happen to you and so the
wise person takes stock of the fact that things are going to get bad is this is
the same thing that happens with Noah.
It's like assume the flood because it's going to happen and you think,
well,
it's a hell of a world that has floods.
It's like not if you have a boat.
Right.
It helps a lot.
If he,
if there's a flood and you have a boat,
it's like you can float on the flood and then it's not such a problem.
And so if you
refuse to look at the fact that things are going to be going downhill badly and
that you're going to be in a pit at some point,
you and your family perhaps then
when it happens,
it will be as bad as it possibly can be.
But if you're awake and alert to that possibility,
then you can mitigate it.
Okay.
And the dearth was in all the lands,
but in the land of Egypt,
there was bread.
And when the land of Egypt was famished,
the people cried to Pharaoh for bread.
And Pharaoh said unto the Egyptians,
go to Joseph what he says to you to do.
You do that.
And the famine was all over the face of the earth.
And Joe Boo Josef opened up the store houses and sold to the Egyptians and the
famine waxed sore in the land of Egypt and all the countries came into Egypt to
buy to Joseph to buy corn because the famine was sore in all the lands.
Now when Jacob saw that there was corn in Egypt,
Jacob said unto his sons,
why are you standing around looking at each other?
He said,
I've heard that there's corn in Egypt,
get down there and I from a buy for us so that we may live and not die.
It's like pretty straightforward advice that,
and Joseph's 10 brothers went down to buy corn in Egypt,
but Benjamin Joseph's brother,
that's the youngest one,
right?
The only one left.
It's the one that was younger than Joseph,
the only youngest one and also Rachael's other suck.
But Jeff Benjamin,
Joseph's brother Jacob didn't send because he was worried that something bad
would happen to them,
which kind of indicates to me that maybe Jacob was a bit suspicious about what
had happened to Joseph the last time he sent all the brothers on a adventure and
Joseph was the governor.
Over all the land and,
and he,
it was sold to all the people of the land in Joseph's brothers came and bowed
down themselves before him with their faces to the earth.
While there's the dream.
Now the thing is too,
is that
one question you have in your life is who should you bow down to?
And you might say,
no one,
that's not exactly the right answer because that means that you don't have an
ideal because you bow down to your ideal.
That's what makes it an ideal.
And if you don't have an ideal,
then what the hell are you going to do?
So you have to bow down to something.
And so what happens here as well,
the brothers are bowing down to the person who is so bloody resilient and
competent that they can take themselves out of a prison and become the ruler of
the land.
That happened to Vaclav Havel,
right?
In Czechoslovakia.
It also happened to
Mandela in South Africa.
These things actually happen.
It's really something.
So God only knows what you might learn in prison.